[موسيقى]
هذا الملف هو اخطر ملف
في
كل
الجمهوريه التونسيه لانه ملف شائك ويحمل
العديد والعديد من
الروابط مع ملفات اخرى تهدد الامن القومي
وهذا الملف هو ملف كبير وفي مئات المتهمين
سواء كانوا سياسيين او امنيين او حتى
مواطنين
معناها
مدنيين يعني هناك العديد والعديد من
المتورطين في هذا الملف وهذا يجعل منه انه
التحقيق يتطلب البعض من الوقت للتثبت
وايلات الاستماعات والى كشف كل الحقائق
الموجوده في هذا الملف وذلك انه تم
العديد من الايقافات بعد
قامت الوحدات بالبحث وقاضي التحقيق
بالاستنقات
[موسيقى]
هناك تم
العديد من
بطاقات الايداع نذكر منهم بطاقه ايداع ضد
علي العريض وهو الرجل الثاني في حركه
النهضه وكان وزير الداخليه ورئيس حكومه في
يوم ما في وقت
معناها
في ملف التسفير هو مورط بشكل انه
وزير داخليه وكان يخفي الحقائق وكان يدعم
بطريقه
وبمسؤوليه تامه ما حدث في تونس في ذلك
الوقت راينا ايضا
العديد من بطاقات الايداع التي تهم
الامنيين وهم مورطين في
تسهيل
وادخال الارهابيين الى تونس واخراج بعض
المواطنين الى
بؤر التوتر وبعض ايضا
المسؤولين مثل نور الدين البحيري وغيرهم
من الناس المتورطه في تدليس جوازات السفر
وغيره
نريد نبحي كان في وقت ما وزير العدل في
حكومه التريكه يعني
ملف التسفير يحتوي العديد العديد من
المتهمين ومن قياده عليا اقل واحد يضر
لمدير عام
وزراء وايضا حتى رئيس جمهوريه سابق الموسم
المرزوقي هو ايضا
متورط في هذا الملف
[موسيقى]